we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
um here is a caller furious with me that
I said yesterday you know neonuclear
could be a bridge to sustainable
Renewable Power uh this this caller is
very angry take a listen David what the
hell are you talking you talking about
Things No Such Thing David they haven't
figured out what to do with the waste
that we make from current nuclear plant
technology
uh metal containers leak up to 30 35
years on the ground leaking liquid
radioactive waste into the soil
and you're talking about new nuclear but
please
quit insulting the audience there's no
such thing as new nuclear no such thing
the bottom line is we've got to get out
of code and oil
that's what we got to do so this is
unfortunately a case where
um the end goal we agree on but we
disagree about the possible role of
nuclear listen I'm not a nuclear
activist I'm not going around saying
let's bring on new nuclear I'm not doing
that I think that we could given that we
can't just get off of oil right now I
think we should just build up go
straight to Renewables but I concede
that I would be lying if I said there
was no case to be made for new nuclear
as a bridge the fears about safety from
the 70s do not apply to new nuclear
technology if we were to use it used
fuel can be recycled in ways we did not
previously know that it could more than
90 percent of its potential energy Still
Remains in the fuel after five years of
use in a reactor we are learning more
and more about storage including dry
Cask storage there are new safer nuclear
reactors that include sodium cooled
fission as well as advanced Fusion uh
the fission technology reduces nuclear
waste and can even use the waste as fuel
so I'm not saying nuclear yo let's do it
I'm saying the reflexive anti-nuclear uh
standpoint of some on the left is based
on 40 year old technology and
understanding of tech of how nuclear
Works
um that's it that's all I'm saying so
let's all relax all right let's let's
simmer down on the bonus show today we
are going to talk about a number of
different things including this uh
trading frenzy another meme stock AMC
stock doubling we will talk about Ron
DeSantis forcing forcing cruise ships to
accept unvaccinated passengers what and
the state is seeking 30 years for Derek
Chauvin for the murder of George Floyd
Derek Chauvin is asking for time served
in probation that's a big gap we'll talk
about all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show I would love it if
you got access to the bonus show today
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
the Memorial Day special code goes until
tomorrow it is memorial 21. really
strong discount all right I'll see
everybody on the bonus show momentarily